[REPORTER QUESTIONS]
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT, THAT WAS
THE PRESIDENT REACTING TO THIS
WEEK'S IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS AND
A BUNCH OF OTHER STUFF.
WE ARE GOING TO WAIT FOR TODAY'S
SECOND HEARING TO START.
THE APARTMENT OF DEFENSE
OFFICIAL, STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL WILL BE TESTIFYING IN A
LITTLE BIT APPEARED EARLIER
TODAY, AMBASSADOR TO THE E.U.,
GORDON SONDLAND, FACING UP WITH
LAWMAKERS.
HE WHIPPED DEMOCRATS INTO A HUGE
FRENZY WHEN HE SAID THIS IN HIS
OPENING STATEMENT.
>> I KNOW THAT MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE FREQUENTLY FRAME THESE
COMPLICATED ISSUES IN THE FORM
OF A SIMPLE QUESTION.
WAS THERE A QUID PRO QUO?
AS I TESTIFIED PREVIOUSLY, WITH
REGARD TO THE REQUESTED
WHITE HOUSE CALL AND THE
WHITE HOUSE MEETING, THE ANSWER
IS YES.
>> AFTER AMBASSADOR SONDLAND,
ADAM SCHIFF QUICKLY RAN TO THE
MEDIA MICROPHONES TO DECLARE
VICTORY AND CASE CLOSED.
THEN THE INVESTOR HAD TO ANSWER
ACTUAL QUESTIONS, AND IT TURNS
OUT, HIS STORY HAS SOME MAJOR
HOLES.
HERE'S ONE EXAMPLE.
>> THERE WERE SO MANY DIFFERENT
SCENARIOS FLOATING AROUND AS TO
WHAT WAS GOING ON WITH UKRAINE,
SO RATHER THAN ASK THE PRESIDENT
NINE DIFFERENT QUESTIONS, IS IT
DOES, IS IT THAT?
I JUST ASKED, WHAT DO YOU WANT
FROM UKRAINE?
I MAY HAVE EVEN USED A FOUR
LETTER WORD.
HE SAID, I WANT NOTHING.
I WANT NO QUID PRO QUO.
I JUST WANT PRESIDENT ZELENSKY
TO DO THE RIGHT THING, OR WORDS
TO THAT EFFECT.
>> Jesse: TODAY WAS A VERY
CONFUSING DAY FOR EVERYONE.
>> Dana: I FOLLOWED ALONG
PERFECTLY.
JUST KIDDING.
>> Jesse: EVEN FOR AMBASSADOR
SONDLAND HIMSELF.
HE SAID THERE WAS NO QUID PRO
QUO.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
WHITE HOUSE MEETING.
HE WANTED A WHITE HOUSE MEETING
BUT NOT UNTIL THEY ANNOUNCED AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE 2016
ELECTIONS AND INTO BURISMA.
THAT IS NOT A CRIME, THAT IS
JUST P.R. FOR P.R. APPEAR THAT
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH MILITARY
AID.
AT THE END OF THE DAY MAYBE THIS
BLOCKBUSTER TESTIMONY WASN'T AS
BLOCKBUSTER AS PEOPLE BELIEVE.
>> Dana: LIKE MOST DAYS FROM
THIS TESTIMONY I'VE HEARD FROM
FRIENDS ON THE LEFT TO SAY,
SLAM-DUNK, AMAZING, WE DID SO
WELL TODAY.
REPUBLICANS SAY, IT'S OVER, NO
PROBLEM, THIS GUY WAS A TOTAL
JOKE.
I THINK BOTH SIDES WILL TRY TO
TELL THEIR STORY AND WE CAN GET
INTO ALL OF THAT.
I FELT LIKE DURING THE HEARING
THAT THE DEMOCRATS WERE EXCITED
TO HAVE HIM AND THEN THEY WERE
LIKE, WAIT, WE ARE NOT SO
EXCITED.
THEN THE REPUBLICANS AND THE
DEMOCRATS GOT SO FRUSTRATED WITH
HIM AND HE WAS JUST THERE
SAYING, I'M JUST TRYING TO DO MY
BEST.
HE IS NOT A NOTETAKER.
AND HIS MEMORY, AS HUMAN
MEMORIES CAN BE, FAULTY.
I'M NOT SO SURE ON THE DAYS COME
OF THE TIMES, THE CALLS, PLUS
THE STATE DEPARTMENT WON'T ALLOW
HIM TO ACCESS HIS RECORD SO HE
CAN'T ACTUALLY GO BACK AND LOOK
AT IT,
SO THEY ARE SO FRUSTRATED, THEN
YOU GET TO THIS QUESTION FROM
REPRESENTATIVE TURNER.
DID NO ONE ON THIS PLANET TELL
YOU TRUMP WAS TYING AID TO
INVESTIGATE HIS CUSTOMER YES OR
NO CUSTOMER CAN HE SAID YES, NO
ONE EVER TOLD ME THAT.
I THINK REPUBLICANS WILL TRY TO
SAY, THERE WE GO.
I TALKED ABOUT POLLS EARLIER
TODAY.
THE POLLS ARE IMPEACHMENT ARE
NOT GOING IN THE DEMOCRATS' A
FAVOR AT ALL.
I SHOULDN'T SAY AT ALL.
BUT THE ONES WE'VE SEEN SO FAR
LIKE IN WISCONSIN, AN IMPORTANT
BATTLEGROUND STATE.
A PERCENTAGE POINTS MORE BEFORE,
PEOPLE SAY, WE DON'T THINK
IMPEACHMENT IS A THING.
HE'S UP AGAINST ALL THE POSSIBLE
OPPONENTS, BUT YOU DON'T HAVE
MANY PERSUADABLE SPEAR DEMOCRATS
ARE GOING TO SAY HE'S GUILTY,
REPUBLICANS WILL SAY HE IS
NOT.
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT ARE IN THE
MIDDLE, I DON'T THINK IT IS
GOING TO BE VERY EFFECTIVE FOR
REPUBLICANS DOES A PERFECT CALL,
NO PROBLEM HERE.
THEY NEED SOME SORT OF OFF-RAMP
SO THEY CAN SAY, THE AID GUIDE
TO THE UKRAINIANS, WE SUPPORT
THE UKRAINIANS, WE ARE FOR
NATIONAL SECURITY, THIS DOES NOT
RISE TO AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE
AND I THINK THAT IS WHERE THE
REPUBLICANS ARE PROBABLY MOST
SUCCESSFUL AFTER THIS.
>> THEY MAY GET AN OFF-RAMP FROM
THE IG REPORT.
GREG, DID YOU WAKE UP AT 9:00
AND WATCH THE HEARINGS
MINUTE-BY-MINUTE?
>> Greg: FIRST I WOKE UP AT
9:00 AND THAT I WALKED HOME.
I SPENT A LOT OF TIME TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHY I UNDERSTAND THIS
BETTER THAN MOST PEOPLE IN THE
MEDIA, AND IT'S BECAUSE I RAN
STUFF FOR A LIVING.
IF YOU MANAGE THINGS.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS EARLIER IN
YOUR OFFICE, WE TALKED ABOUT HOW
ANYONE WHO IS INVOLVED IN
MANAGEMENT, HIRING OR FIRING OR
DEALING WITH BUDGETS, DEALING
WITH HUMAN RESOURCES, WE LOOK AT
THIS GOING LIKE, WOW, THIS IS
JUST HOW THE WORLD WORKS.
AND YOU UNDERSTAND HOW SO MANY
PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA DON'T HAVE A
TALENT STACK.
THEY HAVE A SINGULAR, VERTICAL
EXPERIENCE FROM JOURNALISM IN
HIGH SCHOOL, JOURNALISM IN
COLLEGE, BEING PROMOTED THROUGH
THE RANKS AS A JOURNALIST.
THEY DON'T HAVE A COLLECTION OF
VERSATILE SKILLS, SO THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY JOURNALISTS ARE
SO BAD WRITING ABOUT BUSINESSES
AND THE ECONOMY IS THEY HAVE NO
FINANCIAL BACKGROUNDS.
THEY ARE PATHETIC, RIGHT?
AND THE PEOPLE WHOSE HAIR IS ON
FIRE ON TWITTER, THE MEDIA
REPORT IS, GENERALLY HAVE NO
EXPERIENCE WHATSOEVER IN THE
OUTSIDE WORLD.
THEY DON'T GO TO AN OFFICE AND
HAVE TO DEAL WITH PEOPLE ASKING
FOR RAISES ARE HAVING TO CUT
STAFF.
SO WHEN IT COMES TO ISSUES LIKE
BUSINESS AND EMPLOYMENT AND
HUMAN INTERACTION, THEY ARE
ABJECT FAILURES.
I USE THE EXAMPLE, THERE IS A
PERIOD IN YOUR LIFE AS A
BUSINESSMAN WHERE YOUR PERSONAL
GOALS AND PROFESSIONAL GOALS
COME INSIDE.
JOE BIDEN IS A POLITICAL RIVAL.
YOU INVESTIGATE HIM, HE BENEFITS
THE COUNTRY, AND IT BENEFITS THE
LEADER.
THAT IS WHERE PROFESSIONAL AND
PERSONAL GOALS COINCIDE.
LIKEWISE WE HAVE A GREAT HAIR
AND MAKEUP STAFF AT "THE FIVE."
PERSONALLY, IT MAKES ME LOOK
GREAT.
PROFESSIONALLY, IT HELPS THE
SHOW.
IF I LOOK GOOD, THE SHOW DOES
BETTER.
IF I LOOK LIKE A SLOB, IT DOES
APPEARED IN THIS CASE, THE
PERSONAL AND THE PROFESSIONAL GA
PERSONAL AND THE PROFESSIONAL GS
PERSONAL AND THE PROFESSIONAL GC
PERSONAL AND THE PROFESSIONAL GI
PERSONAL AND THE PROFESSIONAL GD
PERSONAL AND THE PROFESSIONAL G.
IF YOU'RE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND YOU'RE DEALING
WITH THE PERSON WHO MAY BE
DEALING WITH A CORRUPT COUNTRY,
A KNOWN CORRUPT COUNTRY IN THE
PAST OR THE FUTURE, IT WOULD
BENEFIT YOU TO INVESTIGATE HIM
BUT IT BENEFITS OF THE COUNTRY
AS WELL.
AIN'T NO CRIME, JUST A FUN TIME.
>> Jesse: WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESPOND TO THAT?
>> Greg: "I AGREE, GREG" SAYS
JUAN.
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW WHERE TO
START ON THAT ONE.
>> Greg: I DO LOOK GOOD, AND
SO DO YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: ALL RIGHT, I THINK
THIS WAS A BAD DAY FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AND ONE WAY TO LOOK AT IT, IS
ALWAYS TO CHECK OUT WHAT OTHER
PEOPLE ARE SAYING.
TODAY I WAS WITH DANA, WE WERE
DOING THE COVERAGE, AND I
NOTICED THAT KEN STARR AND
ANDY McCARTHY BOTH THOUGHT
TRUMP HAD A BAD DAY.
ESPECIALLY AFTER THAT MORNING
SESSION WHEN YOU HEARD DIRECTLY
FROM AMBASSADOR SONDLAND, IT WAS
DRAMATIC IN TERMS OF THAT
OPENING STATEMENT.
IT WAS CLEAR THAT HE WAS SAYING,
WAS THERE A QUID PRO QUO?
YOU PLAYED THE SOUND BITE AND HE
SAID YES.
HAD HE NOT SAID THERE WAS A QUID
PRO QUO, IT WOULD'VE BEEN
ABSOLUTELY DEFLATING FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
THIS WAS WHAT THE DEMOCRATS HAD
ADVERTISED THAT THIS WAS GOING
TO BE OUR KEY MOMENT.
AFTERWARDS, ADAM SCHIFF SAID
THIS WAS THE SEMINAL MOMENT
TODAY AND THAT IS WHAT IT TURNED
OUT TO BE.
>> Jesse: BUT WHAT WAS THE
QUID PRO QUO FOR?
IT WASN'T AT THE MILITARY AID SO
WHAT WAS IT WAS REX BEFORE THIS
IS WHERE DETAILS, ESPECIALLY FOR
JOURNALISTS, REALLY MATTER.
THE OPENING STATEMENT IN THE
MORNING WHERE HE SAID THERE WAS
QUID PRO QUO, HE SAID IT WAS
WITH PEOPLE WORKING FOR A DRUM.
LATER IN THE AFTERNOON HE SAID
DIRECTLY, THE PRESIDENT HAS
NEVER TOLD ME TO ENGAGE IN A
QUID PRO QUO.
HE HASN'T ASKED ME FOR THAT
DIRECTLY, HE HAS NEVER SAID
THOSE THINGS.
WHILE HE INFERRED WITH PEOPLE HE
WAS WORKING WITH OVERSEAS THAT
MAY BE IS WHAT WAS BEING ASKED
FOR, HE DIDN'T IMPLICATE THE
PRESIDENT DIRECTLY AS AN ORDER
COMING DIRECTLY FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THAT BEING SAID, I DON'T THINK
ADAM SCHIFF REALLY CARES ABOUT
ANY OF THE FACTS OR WHETHER THEY
ARE GOOD OR BAD FOR REPUBLICANS.
HE'S MOVING THIS THING FORWARD
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS.
HE RAN TO THE CAMERAS TO THE
BREAK TO TALK ABOUT ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT THAT HE WANTS TO PUT
FORWARD.
GUARANTEE YOU HE IS GOING TO
WRITE ONE UP ON BRIBERY AND
ANOTHER ONE ON OBSTRUCTION OF
CONGRESS.
HE TALKED ABOUT IT TODAY,
WHETHER THEY ARE VALID OR NOT.